how do you inspire people on social
media so i got a great question from my
newsletter
readers devon love you guys who wrote in
to say
evan i agree with you but i don't have
the answers how would you go about
inspiring others maybe i should start
with linkedin and twitter
what do you think this is a great
question and i'm going to share with you
three tips for how you can inspire
people on social media number one is use
what fits your style
when i first started out doing the
inspirational stuff i started on
facebook i love facebook i was sharing
inspirational quotes and pictures and
i was using photoshop and i you know
those things spoke to me i shared things
that i was excited by that inspired me
and said
this can help other people i'm gonna put
it up on facebook since then i've
gravitated away to spend most of my time
on youtube
i'm still on facebook i use twitter i
use linkedin but my favorite network by
far
is youtube i love being able to answer
questions i love being able to be on
camera
and use my my passion that comes through
to help inspire people
and i think for you and for everybody
watching it's figuring out what
what network fits your style best you
know if you like doing video
get on youtube it makes the most sense
if you're awkward or shy or don't like
being in front of the camera
then it's not going to be great on
youtube right then if you like to write
then maybe twitter is better right you
can write your short
tweets or if you like to write bigger
posts and blog posts maybe you can
have the blog and post those on linkedin
right so it's
it doesn't matter which network you're
going for if you're trying to inspire
others or people on every single
platform
it's really figuring out which one best
fits your style
so you can have the most success number
two is be inspired
if you want to inspire others you have
to be inspired as well
right you have to be excited about what
you're doing what you're sharing
everything that you post has to mean
something to you you know i want
everything i post
to be something that i'm proud of i want
to be able to look back on it and say
wow that's a
i'm really proud that i made that i'm
i'm happy to show that
to my son related to my grandkids to say
look what look what i made right you got
to be that proud of everything that you
put up
so it's not just putting up promotional
crap it's something that
really means something to you that
you're trying to share with the world
if you're not inspired yourself there's
no way you're going to inspire other
people right people
people catch it they catch you sam
walton used to say they catch your
passion like a fever
and so if you're passionate you're
excited they're gonna get passion
excited too
people watch these videos you guys are
you're probably watching this right now
because
you know i'm excited i'm inspired right
now you know i give you some energy to
start your day
where if i was coming on and i was like
you know you need to believe in yourself
it's really important to believe in
yourself because without belief
you don't have anything and you know
that that's my message for today
that sucks right that's not inspired so
it's not going to be
inspiring anybody and with anything
it'll take practice you know if you want
to get good on camera it may take
thousands of takes i've made thousands
of videos so i get better
but you want to make sure that whatever
you're doing is led
with with an inspired intent and you're
proud of everything that you're posting
and number three is be consistent so
many people get this idea i'm gonna go
on social media right i'm gonna launch a
twitter account or a youtube channel and
they go crazy for the first
couple weeks or first couple months and
you're you're posting every day or
multiple times a day
and then it just stops you know becomes
too much work too overwhelming
you can't keep up that crazy schedule
you lose the excitement a little bit
and any momentum that you built up just
stops in its tracks
and you got to realize that for all
these social channels it
it's it's a long game right this is this
is a war this isn't just
a little battle and it takes time for
things to happen
and so you know you may not be seeing
that early momentum you may not be
seeing comments and retweets and shares
but
some people are watching and if you post
good stuff they'll come back
and you might get one comment or one
[ __ ] i remember like the first
you know those videos that i was putting
out go back on my channel some of the
early ones had no comments had no thumbs
ups
and and i remember like if i got one
thumbs up or one comment like wow
somebody's paying attention that gave me
a little fuel to keep going
and so you know i post twice a day on my
youtube channel
there are people who complain that they
can't get one video a month
up on their channel i made it a priority
i'm posting two times every single day
on my channel and that consistency has
led to
growth has led to impacting way more
people and inspiring a much bigger
audience
so you don't have to start twice a day
start once a week but start
and then be consistent every single week
you're posting
if you ramp that up every single day
you're posting
don't take days off don't take weeds off
you can you can pre-schedule this stuff
out too but if you want to inspire
people on social media then you have to
be consistent
so in summary the three ways to inspire
people on social media
number one use what suits your style
number two
be inspired and number three be
consistent
and believe if you guys like this video
you can subscribe to the channel see
more just like it
i'd also love to hear how you're
inspiring people through your social
media channels
leave a comment below to tell me how
you're doing it so that other people can
also learn from it as well
thank you guys so much for watching i'll
see you soon this is a great quest
great great great question it's a great
question
hi i'm thor rafzan from time management
chef dot com
evan carmichael's newsletter epic
subscribe